Now, we're going to talk about
a very different kind of an attack.
This is called inference attacks and
that can be performed or
mounted against databases.
So the definition of an inference attack
is actually fairly straight-forward.
Inference attacks occur when
somebody's able to use queries
that they're authorized for, they're
allowed to execute those queries.
But by executing those queries, they're
able to gain access to information for
which they're not authorized.
They're not allowed to access
that information directly.
So the way they gain access
to that information is by
executing a set of queries that are
authorized, and then making an inference
based on the results that
are returned by those queries.
So a concrete example here, since
we're talking to students in a course,
is let's say a database that
contains all your grades.
So schema, maybe we have an attribute,
that is the studentid,
maybe the student_standing, whether
a junior or senior and then scores.
These might be numerical
values between zero and 100,
let's say, on exam1, exam2 and
then the final_grade.
The tuple, if you look at it, it's
going to have a studentid, either junior
or senior, their standing, the two
exams, course and the final_grade.
So if we consider this database, where
we have a tuple for each student in
the class, tuple as we just discussed,
what kind of query can you allow on it
which any user should be allowed to
submit and get the result from it?